[Music]  Hannity social media sensation foxnews  contributor Tommy Lehren is the final  word tonight Tommy Shawn I have the  final words for Hillary let's go  what happened Hillary you happened you  blamed and continued to blame literally  everyone but funny thing is you let him  full up help from well Obama Michelle  Joe Biden Don Brazil Debbie  wasserman-schultz  the DMC the FBI 90% of the mainstream  media every late-night TV show in the  entire population of Hollywood  loudmouths and you still lost you lost  because you're was relatable as  cardboard and allergic to accountability  and no it's not because the country  wasn't ready for a woman it's because  the country isn't ready for a liar or an  entitled political princess so don't  start with the sexism charade again see  she knows his book to her is bad for her  own party but she doesn't care the most  important thing to Hillary is as always  Hillary Shawn that's a final word